[Musique]
et là bonjour tout le monde est bienvenu
à la randonnée du marché by
ils avaient leurs maris on va passer la
matinée ensemble on va faire des arts
culinaires saint viateur bigorre
à ottawa comme à montréal c'est la folie
des tours culinaire on marche les
instruit et surtout on mange et on vit
depuis une quinzaine d'années dans un
monde chefs vedettes et de là les gens
veulent aller voir ces gens là veulent
connaître puis le tourisme d'aujourd'hui
est pas celui d'il ya 20 ans où on
embarquait dans un autobus ne voulait
pas sortir les gens qui sont plus dans
ma génération a moins je suis capable
trouver l'église notre dame toute seule
je condamne à main on m'amène en
arrière-scène selon dit m la nourriture
est un des thèmes qui fonctionne très
très bien rien eu a pris ce manga est
arrivé on a vu l'année les galaxies
ronald poiré est un pionnier tour
culinaire
une façon originale de voir la ville qui
est de plus en plus populaire on va
rendre ici mais je faire comprendre aux
gens sont absentes jeunes qu'à l'image
au restaurant le xingu sa capote 50 ans
ça date d'à peu près 25 ans donnait 2 de
la viande le fameux creton que je
parlais tout à l'heure ses névroses à
tamanrasset et lyon c est à qui fait
maison
c'est une amazone
confère à plier à cette environ deux
heures grand on rentre ses différents
commerces se déterminer on essaye de
parler aux gens pour vraiment ressentir
leurs pensions que le pétrole le plus
fort en goût à cause du niveau
les gens vont goûter à quelque chose à
sa place
cette référence depuis ça comme ça plus
qu'un morceau de copier
de fait
bonjour goûter à des cerises dispersés
sur l'hers et pour wii c
au marché by à ottawa c'est le visite
gourmande permet de découvrir les
produits locaux mais aussi toute la
diversité culinaire de la ville
ça c'est le pas d'annoncés plus est un
peu plus jeune de la légère c'est là que
tu peser dans un ministre ça c'est elle
catane et gouda les gens bien sous verre
sur le marché les mots toujours la même
place allant d'août on les a mises en
place ou peut-être aurait pas pensé à
les voir
[Musique]
le tabac les sacs à merde alors
viennent chercher disent qu'il faut à
vienne salée pour le chef
jeudi le jour même sur le mélange de
plus
soleil chaleur et bonne humeur
la journée parfaite pour découvrir le
quartier du mas hélène de montréal en
compagnie de notre guide en tant que
grand mali décès de bruce et de
présenter des commerçants ou des
restaurateurs des restauratrices qu'ils
font et année la scène culinaire
montréal et qui carrément à l'explosion
dans tous les quartiers de la ville en
ce moment grâce aux aides accordées en
tête de ces taux de l'inr vient surtout
du canada anglais les etats unis
critiquent de 6 août du toulinguet money
au besoin ou en français quand on nous
le demande
il reste maintenant à séduire la
clientèle francophone européenne les
français sont les grands
un consommateur de tourisme culturel
donc que mon premier dans les musées ils
reconnaissent mandat comme destination
culturelle
on n'est pas vue comme une destination
gourmande pour un français mais quand il
rentre dans notre univers bon là ils ont
une grande grande surprise une grande
surprise mais le sérieux
ces visites se font souvent à pied
parfois à vélo ou encore en transport en
commun
on peut prendre quelques minutes pour
regarder la pitié elles sont ponctuées
darel où s'entremêlent anecdotes
historiques et gourmandises s'y
promènent à face au real le premier
marché public de montréal
l'histoire est fêté par des hommes par
des gagnants et puis des craintes est
des fois il ya des pans d'histoire sont
contradictoires
c'est important de si vous venez
d'ailleurs vous avez entendu une
anecdote ferrand daniel de l'échangé en
histoire de nourriture c'est difficile
d'affirmer à 100 % ce qui s'est passé le
monsieur qui dit si monsieur marionnet
harry pour travailler au pavillon de la
france et les bouchers ont montré
comment faire des pâtes et des rillettes
la charcuterie des choses comme ça
chocolats geneviève grandbois chinois
c'est l'amanda farine une expérience des
quartiers
non seulement par le vent à l'acte
[Musique]
vous avez dit oui on aime ça j'adore ça
c'est mon projet de retraite
je m'amuse à faire ça oui qu'est ce que
valait retenir de ce tour qu'on mange
bien montréal et que c'est beau montréal
les gens sont souriants et
je vais refaire l'expérience sans aucun
doute
[Rires]
[Musique]